[Music]
hello Vernon and welcome to the first
endgame class on YouTube of course we
have insane in the endgame earlier in
the week with the resident Grandmaster
and King and pawn we're for warfare I
don't know if that one's made it to
youtube yet but today it is the
Wednesday and game class with yours
truly
Caleb Denby today I wanted to take a
look at a very specific end game that
first appeared I believe on the internet
chess club in fact it's such a unique
and interesting end game that they made
it its own chess variant on ICC now few
chess variants have so little changes to
chests that they are in fact just a
normal chess position
you know chess960 you get a new position
every time but this endgame is so unique
and so interesting in so game-changing
to the game of chess that it was
qualified as its own variant on a sec so
why don't we take a look at the starting
position of this variants here we have
white with a king on d1 and three pawns
on the Queen side in black with a king
on e8 and three pounds on the Kings side
now this is a very very strange position
of course that probably wouldn't arise
from a normal game of chess although you
know it theoretically could but here the
idea of the game is that generally white
pushes these pawns on the Queen side the
black King has to go stop them and the
black pushes these pawns on the Kings
side and white has to go stop them now
to understand this game I want to take a
step even further back and look at this
position here now a lot of you are
probably familiar with pawns being
connected and defending each other right
when the pawns are connected you can
push up on forward the King can never
take any of the pawns because the other
pawns promote what you might not realize
is that pawns one file apart also defend
each other in this manner so for that
reason white is completely winning in
this position despite his King being all
the way on a one
for example simply king b2 and now if
this King tries to commit to taking the
F pawn well this H pawn can push forward
now
if the King steps back we can pass with
this King again in fact we don't even
need to bring the King into the game
King g6 we pushed this pawn forward now
if King f h5 we pushed this pawn forward
King age 6 we pass and if the kingdom's
back up to age 5 we can bring the King
in but you kind of see how the pawns
push forward in this manner note that
after King g8 it'd be a mistake to push
the pawns because then the black King
could capture but the point is the pawns
defend each other from any king's
advances now how does that apply to this
position well it means that the pawns
and the king always end up in a type of
zoogs Vong when paired up against each
other like this for example here the
King doesn't really want to move if the
King picks a side well then of course
the pawns can advance and the pawns
definitely don't move the pawns advance
well they just get captured so this idea
of Zuke's Vung is used in this endgame
and this is how games end up being so
decisive and how there are actually very
very few draws in this endgame in
practical play now I just wanted to show
you what a game of this might look like
with some naive players players who
don't know a lot about the endgame and
just kind of push you imagine you know
they might want to push the pawn like
might also want to push the pawn
something like a 5 now black has to step
inside the pawn square or else white
will promote so King d7 King need to and
maybe black starts pushing this pawn
White's start pushing starts pushing
this pawn black brings the King in c4
makes sense
f5 you know just push the pawns up the
board b5 check King c5 King f3 for
example h4 for example why not push a6
rather than king b6 what if G for King F
for King b6 of course it'd be a mistake
to take care because the pawns would
promote so you can imagine c5 check now
if
you take either of these pawns then this
pawn promotes so king a7 is forced and
then a move like Seif c6 might be played
and after King b6 we have arrived at a
type of zoogs Vung on the Queen side
here note that no matter which pawn gets
pushed the black king could capture also
note that if the black King ever has to
move well then the white pawn could push
and promote this is the type of mutual
zoogs Vung that I'm talking about here
the King can't really move and the pawns
can't really move either so what that
means is this game is now going to be
decided by the Queen side and in this
case and this naive play it turns out
blacks pawns are simply too far advanced
and he is going to end up winning this
game just by pushing to victory so
that's what kind of an a naive game
might look like you end up with this
type of mutual Zook swung and then the
game is decided on the other side of the
board now let's look like look at what a
game might look like between a naive
player and a player who does know some
strategy in this endgame so white might
just start pushing with random moves and
let's say black knows what he's doing
starts with H 5 and H 4 now this King
comes up and you have this nice move f5
and so what we have here is after King G
2 and F 4 we have this situation that we
first looked at in this first position
here these pawns defend each other the
King cannot step to either side or else
the pawns will start start pushing
forward and so what this means is black
has successfully locked the pawns on the
King side he's locked down this
situation white can't ever really get at
either of these pawns but he's done so
in a very very specific way the way he's
done it is with just these two pawns
leaving this pawn on g7 now why is that
relevant well we're going to see later
in this game white tries pushing a 4 for
example King d7 c4 king decent King c6
a5 King B 7 B five black passes for a
little bit and after
see five there are a couple moves that
win I like the move King v8 and now
whichever pawn white pushes the black
king is simply going to stuff in front
of it
for example of b6 simply king b7 forces
these pawns in deserts Vong if a six
king a7 forest is a move like c6 and now
king b6 forces the pawns in the souk
song and if c6 simply king c7 and you
get the same identical position let's
look at a six king e7c six King b6 for
example and now white is in the awkward
position where he can't do anything with
his pawns and his King is limited to
these two squares on g1 and g2 so if he
steps this way of course h3 is going to
be winning the game now the pawns are
too far advanced if King h3 well he's
also going to lose the game to the move
f3 this is how these two pawns defend
each other so the only thing you can do
is pass with King g1 now my question to
those of you at home is find the winning
move for black in this position and then
hopefully that'll explain why it's so
key for black to leave this pawn back on
g7 see if you can find the winning move
for black here
the winning move for the black pieces
it's not so easy
so there are two conflicting answers of
course there's two practical moves here
it doesn't make so much sense to push
either of these pawns because the King
will simply take them right if you take
if you push then the King comes and
takes we saw this in that first endgame
that I showed now the two practical
moves of course you can't move the King
either or else why it will promote so
the moves you have as options are g6 and
g5 now who sees the difference between
g6 and g5 here who sees the difference
who sees what the difference is
see if you can type out the full line in
the chat that shows the difference one
of these moves loses the other move wins
g6 gets cigs Vong ok what's the line
what's the line
show me the line I want to see the line
g6 will give you an extra move g5 stops
the king the chat is still split the
chat is still split
g6 and I'm in zoogs long after g5 saves
the tempo fair enough
g5 protects g6 does not the chat is
totally totally split here now here's
the thing you know exactly what whites
next in Infinity moves are right if
white ever steps this way well then f3
wins
if white ever steps this way then Age 3
wins the same goes for F 2 and H 2 it
doesn't make a difference you can just
push the pawn and then you win just to
show you what that looks like you step
up now you push this way and there's
nothing you can do to stop these pawns
there's just nothing you can do there's
simply nothing to be done so since the
white king is locked on these two
squares you know that these are his next
infinite moves unless you stop them
somehow so because of that you can
calculate all the way to the end of the
line and that's what this variant is
about and so if you play the move g5
well then King G 2 G for King G 1
now if G 3 wait a second you are the one
in zoogs Vung and if you play h3 well
then after King H 2 this move hangs h3
so you have to play f3 and then once
again it's now black to move and if it's
black to move here and he's forced to
move his King well then white simply
promotes and this is the sad truth of
the game that's why it's so important
for black to leave this pawn back on g7
this is the quote-unquote strategic play
that I was talking about from black he
leaves this pawn all the way back on g7
the only Square where it has a choice of
Tempe and here because black can choose
to play g6 instead of g5 black is
winning the game now if King g2 King g5
g for king g2 is forced and now after g3
it is white who has to flinch first if
white plays King h3 and f3 white please
please King f3 than h3 if he steps back
well now simply h3 and once again this
is busted
as we see here and so that is the key
strategy for black black once to set up
with f5 and h4 in this manner so that
whenever the White King steps back to g2
you can play at four and so that's kind
of the crux of this game you can force a
win of this mutual Zook swung by saving
this tempo with the pawn so unless
absolutely forced you never really want
to be pushing this Jeep on forward
unless you've already calculated to the
end and you already see that the zoogs
Vung is winning for you now let's see
what strategic play looks like you know
against each other so here we have a 4
h5 kingi to h4 the king of three f5 this
is a really nice setup for black of
course he leaves this pawn back on g7
these two pawns defend each other and
then at the end of the line he's going
to pick either g6 or g5 to try to win
the game now white might go for
something similar on the Queen side for
example a 5 c4 King c6 and now just for
example what if white plays the move
King G - well black is probably gonna
play the move f4 now what do you think
white should play in this position after
f4 what should white play here can white
do the same well we're taking a look
here was saying what if white does try
to do the same thing and just leave his
pawn on b2
I'll give you a hint one move draws only
one move here draws I won't tell you if
other moves win or lose but only one
move draws
I'm seeing only twitch chat no this is
only being streamed to you to only
reading this YouTube chat since I
Krishna says the movie for interesting
to people say be for one person says a
five a five I think might hang upon I
think King B 6 can just go take that a
five pound unfortunately just note says
B 3 so you guys aren't quite getting the
idea yet so of course in this end game
as I said the key is the the power of
choice black with a pawn on g7 can
choose to play g6 or g5 depending on
where the king is when the the Tempe are
flushed out so with the move b4 well now
black is free to lock the pawns on the
Kings side with his king no matter which
way it happens for example like this and
once this happens well we have the same
position as we had the first time black
once again has the power of choice once
again g6 ends up being the correct move
here he gets to choose which of the the
Tempe are required now even if the
situation on the Kings side works out
differently on the Queen side or other
works out differently for example King
c7 you know b6 for example King b7 so
sorry so even if it works out
differently just for example here King
g1 and then came back to be 8 and now b6
black still has the power of choice
kingi 2 now even though the King is on
the other square in this position black
can choose the other pawn move to still
win the game it doesn't matter where the
White King is if it's on g1 well I can
play g6 if it's on g2 but I can play g5
and either way he ends up winning the
Tempe he ends up putting white into zigs
long so the point is it's the power of
choice that's important and b4 gives up
this power of choice so after before
white is simply
dead lost so I'll ask you once again
what is the only move to draw for white
in this position once again I will ask
you the only move to draw hello NLA
hello hello see if you can find the only
move that draws
I'm still waiting in the chat to catch
up here okay it looks like some people
are getting it now
c5 doesn't make any sense that just
hangs upon don't don't hang your pot b3
b3 doesn't work for the same reason that
b4 doesn't work it's not the difference
of B three verses before the difference
is you've given up the choice of playing
b4 or b3 now you're committed you're
locked in and because black is choosing
second black can decide whichever one is
best for him so b3 also loses the game
but some of you have it right now g1 is
of course the only drawing move King g1
you do not commit to your B pawn move in
that way now if black is the one who
commits first white is going to be the
one who wins the game just for example
g5g for g3 if black commits in this
manner
well now white is the one who gets the
power of choice with this beep on and
here why does the one who's winning
after b3 forcing the Zug so something to
be aware of so after King g1 perhaps
blacks best mood is just to play
something like either King c5 and came
back to c6
or for example King b7 and then you get
this funny looking draw where neither
side commits to moving their pawns and
the game is drawn by repetition so this
is kind of what strategic play looks
like in this game both sides try to go
for this kind of setup where if the
other side commits well then they lose
the game now I wanted to show you guys
one more interesting draw that is
available in this endgame so let's see
what happens in this other interesting
drop so let's say white starts Kimi to
King d7 a4 for example h5 u f3 f5 King
f4 and you know h h4 this is what i mean
by saying the pawns defend each other
the King steps up well h4 can come on
now you can't take this pawn because
okay so a five here King c6 c4 and now
let's say it black breaks all the
principles I just told you
place the move g5 check plays the move
g5 check King f3 and then he continues
to move g4 check King at 4 h3 King has
to come back to g3 f4 check King H to f3
King g3 let me ask you guys the
evaluation of this position do you think
White's winning do you think black
spooning or do you think it is a draw
what's the evaluation of this position
what do you think
I didn't ask you guys for a chess move I
asked you for the evaluation of the
position is it a win for white is it a
win for black or is it a drill White's
winning just did this white win white
wins draw what is winning he has the
initiative with b3 and b4 black is
winning white wins so under normal
circumstances you would in fact expect
white to be winning why would you expect
that well I've just explained to you
white has the power of choice why it
chooses when he wants to move this pawn
so if the black King steps back expects
c5 kim ji-won and now the move b3 would
of course win the game
the king has to repeat and there's
nothing besides this move when black is
the one who has to break the zoogs wong
and allow white to promote now chess
however isn't always so simple
what if black plays King's c5 here well
now white in fact still has the option
of Tempe here and in fact b4 is the
better choice for him if the black King
steps back
well now a6 can you see seven and c5
came back and c6 and once again the
black King has to decide and ends up
losing and if the black King steps back
up here and just for an example if it
steps over to b6
sorry b5 now if King c7 and once again
the white pawns are simply too far
advanced and they will win the game so
it looks to all appearances that white
is winning but who sees the drawing idea
for black black in fact is drawing this
game how can it be done how can it be
done
how can life draw
nobody sees it nobody sees the the draw
everybody's saying f2 but that that just
hangs the pawn right and it's our only
one person saying f2 after H 2 now these
just lose the puns these don't change
the evaluation of the position at all
once you give up upon like this in fact
it's it's even worse for you because now
it's not mutual Zug it's just just
subbed for black the white king can
always repeat with King G King h2 and
King g3 and the black pawns as soon as
they touch as soon as you touch your
black pawns they both fall h2 would fall
and g3 would fall as well so those moves
don't work those moves don't work this
is kind of the mind game that this does
variant plays on you you start to think
of the chessboard is cut in half you
start to think that the Queen side is
one thing the Kings side is another
thing but in fact that is not always the
case
and yeah I'll Kirsch in fact has the
answer you can in fact bring the King to
c5 and after b4 you are just in time to
bring the King to support the pawns and
after a seven f2 Queen a eight Queen f1
and this is going to be just just a
simple draw you can give some checks
black in fact might even be trying to
win but it's it's gonna be a draw in in
the long run no matter what happens so
this is another interesting way for the
game to end in a draw so it seems as
though that's um no matter what happens
here black is always going to be able to
draw and in fact this line with g5 isn't
even forced for black you can simply
play a move like King a c5 and just play
out this position here and now once
again my question for you is white
winning in this position is black
winning in this position or is it a draw
because black could go for this instead
of playing the move and the move g5
himself black could go for this
what's the evaluation of this position
what can be done
draw draw draw draw draw yeah you guys
are all too smart of course that if
white plays a move like King f3 then the
move g5 is actually just simply winning
you know this King steps back for Kings
ugh
now the tempi work out for black and
white is put into the zoo's Vong but of
course he has the same drawing idea that
black had in the previous position with
king e5 now h3 and both sides are just
barely and getting their Queens on the
board and it's going to be the same draw
that we saw in the previous position so
my question now is is this position
drawn yeah you are exactly right Kevin
Kim it's exactly the same as the
previous my question for you is this
position drawn at first glance it seems
like there's just no way to force a win
here going back to our strategic play
scenario it seems as though that even if
Mike King g2 were forced the move f4 can
still come on the board and then white
can simply pass neither side really
committing to pushing this beep on Angie
pawn respectively
so how possibly on this planet could
white win in the initial position for
example even if you try King f4 like now
has this choice of draws with King c5 or
g5 check it seems like we've analyzed
everything we've analyzed everything
right we've analyzed everything so
what's the evaluation of the initial
position I'll give you a hint for those
of you at home with computers if you
turn on stock fish in the initial
position let it run for a long long time
you might get to like depth 40 or
something you know what it's gonna say
it's gonna play say zero point zero zero
zero however for those of you really
dedicated you really dedicated engine
users if you if you turn on your your
super well not quite soo if you turn on
your your high-end computer and you put
in this position
and you say think and you wait about a
week and a half you might get to depth
sixty-five you know what happens a depth
65 white wins at death 65 and so how on
this earth can white win this game well
the trick is I'll give you a hint I
won't give you the answer just yet I'll
give you a hint the trick is the draw
seems to happen after white after black
achieves this setup when black achieves
this setup with f5 and h4 the white king
is in fact kind of stuck it doesn't
really have any options right can come
up to c5 and our sorry up to f4 not c5
and from f4 black has this nice draw
with g5 check where it pushes his pawns
forward gets the F pawn to f3 and then
can bring the King in to support it as
we just saw in the interesting draw or
the White King can step back here when
after f4 the king is kind of locked to
these two squares and of course once we
arrive at a position like this neither
side is going to be touching their pawns
anymore and the kings are going to have
to repeat on their b and g files
respectively so what's the key for white
well the key is of course you prevent
black from getting this setup with f5
and h4 so who thinks they see how you
can prevent the setup for black how can
white prevent this f5 h for setup I'll
leave it in the initial position here
and give you guys some time to figure it
out how can you force black to not get
this drawn set up because we've analyzed
that f5 h 4 set up no matter what white
does black is going to have the power of
choice with his jeep on with f5 and h4
so the best we can do is also keep the
power of choice so that he doesn't lose
lose the game
go for a run with your pawns
kingi to to f3 how does that stop how
does that stop the setup I need the line
that stops h5 h4 + f5 you guys are
giving me the first move
it's not enough how do you ever stop f5
h 5 h floor from black how do you stop
it
if you don't do anything I play f5 i
play h5 i play h4 my next move and I've
achieved a draw
can you to to f3 to g4 Kingi for highly
illegal
I've played f5 and h5 and I'm going to
play h4 yeah Jacob T grave has the
answer you go King e2 white plays h5 you
go King f3 black plays at five and then
you play king g3 and this has prevented
black from achieving his ideal setup
with the pawns on f5 and h4 but it seems
as though black still has this like you
know this is power of choice this power
of choice like I've been saying with
this pawn on g7 so how does it make a
difference well let's say King g7 a
natural move black doesn't want to touch
these pawns he wants to keep his pawn on
g7 well now white can play move like a
four well I can play a move like QC 6
well I can play move like c4 or sorry
wait
I can play move like king b6 so let me
ask you how does white win in this
seemingly identical position black is
also prevented white from achieving c4
in a f5 so why isn't this one drawn
what's the difference here what's the
difference
what is the difference
who sees how white can win this game
now this variant it's all about
calculation it's simple enough that you
can see straight to the end of the line
so see if you can find it see if you can
find the end position
so the first move of course as you all
have said in the chat is this move b4 it
turns out that b4 is simply winning here
for white and that is not what you would
naturally logically expect in all the
previous games we've seen a setup where
you end up in let's say this type of
position just just for fun this type of
position and whoever commits first with
the b-pawn or the Jeep on ends up losing
the game because once you commit to
moving the pawn the opponent has the
power of choice so what's the difference
here why does b4 win when black still
has this power of choice well let's say
King b7 for example when it plays a5
King a 6 C 5 King B 5 it seems as though
Black has favorably locked the pawns on
the Queen side and still has the power
to choose how he wants to lock things up
on the Kings side he has this g6 or g5
so what's the difference here or did I
miss play it with white maybe I miss
played it with white and gave black the
win you guys tell me what's the
difference what's the difference
and also how do you win with whites
does anybody see Aleksandra says it's a
draw
now this is one position that will
absolutely positively never be a draw
either white wins or black wins and the
reason for that is this mutual zoogs
Wong on the queenside
so with this mutual Zook swung on the
queenside
if black ever has to move white wins if
white ever has to move black wins he
takes the pawn that's just how it goes
and because these four pieces are locked
like this black is always going to have
to be moving pawns one funny thing about
pawns they can't pass the White King it
can pass the black pawns cannot pass
so either black pushes the pawns and
ends up with a favorable position on the
Kings side or black pushes the pawns and
ends up with a losing position on the
Kings side and it's your task to figure
out which one that is now in all of the
previous positions that we've seen where
black has a pawn on g7 black ends up
with a favourable position on the Kings
side the reason for that at some point
he chooses either g6 or g5 depending on
which move is better for him in the
moment so I'm asking you now what's the
difference why does this power of choice
not matter here why is white winning
okay so Makoto da says King f4 and one
other person in the chat is saying King
f4h for kingi five well you are simply
far too slow here simply far too slow
Queen by far too slimy a single move too
slow but yeah black is gonna be winning
this game he Queens in time so that's
not it that's not it
chestnut I don't really understand that
line King F or whatever black plays King
g5 so here king f4 is met with h4 and
you can't play King g5 or else black
Queens this is the position we saw at at
the start with these two ponds they
defend each other against this King
so yeah the difference is the pawns on H
five instead of H four but why does that
matter why does that matter
so Jimmy James has suggested the move
King G 2 for white and of course this is
the most natural move and so I don't
know if you guys are going to be able to
find why this actually matters so I'll
give it to you the difference of course
is that blacks pawns are not as far up
the board as they once were and so since
white has forced this position on the
Queen side to be locked down already
black has no choice now but but to start
pushing these pawns and because he has
this power of choice you would expect
him to be winning here in the previous
positions we've always seen something
like this where black chooses either g4
g5 now and then wins the game depending
on the sug but since the pawns are a
little bit farther back depending on
what what black does for example g6 can
be met with King g5 and after g5 King g2
and white wins the xug and now black
will have to move and of course white
will push and promote so g6 doesn't work
cuz of King g3 and of g5 now what does
black what does white do to win the game
how does white win the game after g5
this is the power of choice that we've
seen so I'll give you hints if we in
fact had this position again with these
pawns here the reason black is winning
here is if the King steps up he's
thugged if the King steps to his side
what do we do we push the other pod and
are simply promoting so what's the
difference in sorry this position after
g5 how do you win
okay I'm seeing a lot of mixed answers
here I'll be novices kingi three Ryan
Connor says King g3 John Elias is kim
ji-won interesting so this is going to
be posted again yes it's going to be up
as a video I believe okay so of course
the most principled way to win in this
case I believe it's just play move like
King edge - and the point is now if you
push g4 you get sucked
if you push h4 well you get served right
and if you push f4 well now find the
only winning move for white in this
position the only way to win the only
way to do it
King edge 3 has been suggested teenage 3
well you get Zug everybody and their
grandma thinks it's King age three I've
never been more disappointed in my life
you guys King age three you have to
calculate f3 King g3 g4 King F to h4
guess who got sucked
guess who got slugged it's you guys you
guys got slugged you guys got slugged
look at that you got Zug you got slugged
disaster
of course King edge 3 is not going to do
it oh my gosh now they're all saying
kingi - oh my gosh
King G - oh my gosh you guys oh my gosh
does Kim's you to work no oh my gosh yes
now we're in this situation again or you
have to pick a side or come back and ya
got subbed you got sucked of course the
reason that white is winning in this
position is it is not black who has the
power of choice it is not black who has
the power of choice it is white who has
the power of choice because the black
pawns were further back white could step
out to h2 and now depending on the
position of the black pawns he chooses
g2 or g1 in order to make the Tempe in
his favor that is why white is winning
he is the one with the power of choice
not black he gets to choose g2 or g1 and
of course in this case King G 1 is the
correct Tempe for black now G for King G
to h4 king g1 and no matter which pawn
gets pushed white will step in front so
once again just to show you guys if f4
we have to play king g1 now if g4 king G
to h4 back and now if g3 black gets
sucked just some other wins for you if
after King g1 f3 is tried of course just
King f2 and once again now it is black
who is in the suits long if h3 King g3
is stopped
the ponds so now let me ask you guys
what if F just for example g6 gets
played and just to make things
interesting
why it plays the move King age 2 and
black plays the move f4 what do you
think should be played here
kingi one King g2 what should be played
or maybe King a niche three or maybe
King edge what should be played
what can be played
everybody's sinking h-11 person says g1
of course the answer here is to play the
move King G - what's the difference from
the previous example and the previous
example
white black played g5 making the Tempe
workout so that black white had to go to
g1 now with the pawn on g6 rather King
g2 makes the Tempe work out because
black is spending an extra turn just
just to show you guys that's how the
Tempe workout now if white makes the big
blunder King g1
well the Tempe no longer work out it is
white who ends up sucked okay so all of
that is to say white wins here because
he is the one with the power of choice
he gets to play this move king h2 in
response to g5 oh sorry
let's say c5 can be 5 he's the one who
gets to choose in response to g5 king h2
with the power of choice of king g1 or
king g2 when it is black who is the one
that gets put into zoogs one so that is
all to say the starting position of this
variant is in fact a win for white
stockfish at depth 40 not going to find
it
stockfish at depth 65 that's good enough
so that is the evaluation of this end
game now just a few quick notes on the
practical play of this variant if you
want to go out there beat all your
friends at this variant i actually don't
recommend you run your king to g3
straight away cuz that's an idea that
they can repeat for themselves once they
get the white pieces I definitely
recommend just going for this setup
against them and then watch them all
crumble and play moves like g5 when it's
just going to be dead lost for them
because you have the power of choice
from there it's just a matter of
calculating the Tempe deciding whether
or not in fact you are the one winning
with
extra Tempe another note on trying to
beat your friends with this if they kind
of copy your setup I recommend stepping
back here and then watching them push
their Jeep on they just don't understand
that you need this power of choice and
so that's how you can beat your friends
all the time at it and once they do
finally catch on maybe then you play
King e2 can you have three King g3 and
then you say okay that's that's enough I
think I've proven my point so that's how
I recommend you play it practically
lastly I have one more question for you
guys
one more question what is the evaluation
of this position it's a lot like the
variance we just looked at but with one
difference of course the Kings are just
one step further away
what is the evaluation of this position
is it a win is it a drop is black
winning
what do you guys think it's a draw black
to win might got Terry Terry thinks
white is currently in zug and would be
better off not moving it's interesting
draw draw draw I don't have any friends
to trick unfortunate unfortunate white
wins so what is the difference here the
Kings are step further away so of course
it is a draw King D - what's the drawing
move for black how does black draw here
how can black draw
how do you do it how do you draw you
guys all said draw King DT you got a
draw me now
yeah you all see it of course either f5
or h5 our drawing here with the idea
after King III and King at four you play
the move h4 now once black achieves f5
and h4 this game is completely and
totally drawn neither side can make
progress because the second one side
commits to moving this beep on that's
the second they lose the power of choice
that's the second that they lose the
game unless of course they have their
pawns far enough advanced to promote the
C pawn that's the other way this could
could end in a draw so perhaps this
would in fact be a better chess variant
then the current wild seven that's on
ICC once again if you missed the opening
of the lecture this initial position
here is actually taken from the internet
Chess Club they have a quote unquote
variant of chess which follows all the
same chess rules except this is the
starting position and it works as a
variant because it's so different than
normal chess if the King and pawn
endgame that all comes down to mutual
zoogs long so of course the way to try
to win is to try and get your opponent
to fix your pawns
on one side of the board and once you
achieve that
you want them to lose the power of
choice and with this power of choice
either b3 or B 4 you can win the game so
you lock the pawns over here
now King V 8 and you can calculate from
here the King stuck on these two squares
is only going to be able to go back and
forth and white can pick either b4 or b3
whichever one makes the Tempe workout
for him for example here b3 b4 and black
is in zoogs long so that is all I have
for you guys today this is one of my
favorite variants you can spend a lot of
time looking at these positions I'm
claiming that is a conclusive analysis
of the endgame the endgame
is solved it is of course a win for
white with this idea of kini to to f3 to
g3 blocking off black structure other
than that if black achieves f5 and h4
you can expect a draw with best play
hopefully you all enjoyed hopefully you
go out try this and game 4 for yourself
it's a lot of fun and even knowing the
answer you're quite likely to mess it up
once or twice but with that in mind
thank you all for watching and I will
see you next time
[Music]
you